[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to white from the c3 award think
of them for the Oscars we'll be bringing
you all the best bet from tonight's
ceremony Erin factor in London's big
identities including the tech and
gadgets that have had the biggest impact
over the past year the music legend
Garry Newman on why he prefers working
with computers to people and I'm going
to be telling you what I think are the
best innovations in gaming over the last
industries big name giant winner the
decided for a combination of a public
judges were ticketed heels truly look at
who won big on the night here's the
thing about tech every year seems to be
better than the last because generally
it is 2017 was no exception Samsung made
a return scooping phone of the year
beating out Apple certainly a big
comeback following last year's saga with
a galaxy note 7 the model hit headlines
after a series of battery fires and
handsets
but the launch of their new Galaxy s8
was well received it's really excited
place for us to be bringing new
technologies innovation enabling
customers to live the life to their full
potential and capture fantastic moments
we may be at BAFTA but the t3 awards are
known as the Oscars of tech and if
that's right the evenings moonlight was
the Amazon echo taking home awards
including the top prize hi there the
device was class this year's top gadget
as well as taking home innovation and
smart home product of the year and it's
no surprise tech junkies have been
inviting Alexa into their homes around
the world and as an echo was the
must-have device of the past few months
and as Amazon continues on its path to
world domination the echo stands at the
forefront of its operation goodbye
customers seem to love talking to alexa
to an engagement alexa it's early days
with super happy with engagement
customers have got and tonight's just a
very special night
bang & olufsen stunned critics with its
seamlessly stylish BeoSound shape a
sound system that would look no more out
of place in the Guggenheim than on the
wall of a living room consumers today
they want technology to blend in and
support their lifestyles and not to
stand out and be just black spots aside
as we've seen previously adding a bit of
energy to the evening was Anki overdrive
sky electrics for the 21st century
it was given the evenings fun award what
you used to actually it's like bringing
these little toy cars to life they're
getting this a race around the track
getting to play with them have a great
experience with him and if out of New
Year modern day world despite picking up
best SmartWatch Apple was conspicuously
absent from the list of top winners but
with the upcoming launch of the iPhone
10 2018 could be the company's year
Thomas Newton Sky News one of the most
prestigious awards has to be tech legend
and this year's winner is a British
electro pioneer whose music has inspired
the likes of prints and Depeche Mode
he's just released his 22nd album and
he's always been known for pushing the
limits of Technology ladies and
gentlemen I give you Gary Numan
[Music]
[Applause]
some songs never grow old and maybe in
Gary Newman's case that's because his
electronic sound in the late 70s and
early 80s was way ahead of his time
I've been selected was number one for a
month but number one single why now but
at the same time then a few months later
put out cars and from a different album
and that was number one in both charts
at the same time but every Pioneer has
to fight some resistance from a public
point of view it was massive amazing but
within the music business itself there
was some people that were massively into
it and supportive but luckily but there
were plenty of others I think I think
there were a lot of people who saw it as
a threat to the guitar dominance that
they'd been for such a long time the
Musicians Union for example said that I
was putting real musicians out of work
which apartment been incredibly
something it was actually really
ignorant because if they'd listened to
what I was doing there wasn't any sound
I was making that was remotely but
somebody an orchestra would mine despite
the haters it was his fascination with
synthesizer technology that pushed him
forward I was trying to find some weird
growly balm and things you know you show
me an instrument that makes that that's
what attracted me to it
that he was a it was a machine that
could make noises that you'd never heard
before so I wasn't trying to you know
put string sections that work
nearly 40 years on with his 22nd album
out and at a time when technology and
music combined everyday I wanted to know
how he keeps his sound fresh the
interesting thing is trying to find a
way of making noises musical and that's
fun as far as I'm concerned so a lot of
it will come from synthesizers and
software morosely these days and then
partly synthesizers but Lobby doesn't
you know a lot of it comes from other
places these particular days on the
Underground and I noticed as the train
slowed down then it made this amazing
howling sound tell of what it is but it
sounds great so I went back and I've got
my look recorded from the hotel went
back on a train it's been some time and
it just trying to get a clean recording
of this sound
[Music]
winning this year's tech Legend Award
seems fitting for a man who's always
made the most of technology in his music
there's also a very personal reason Gary
feels comfortable around machines and
it's to do with his form of autism
we have tendencies though we obsess we
big we get obsessed about things my way
of thinking just means we're incredibly
focused you know but it's called it's
considered to be obsession you know
where everything is just that for a
while you know well I think that's a
brilliant thing to have if you're if
you're doing music for a career you need
to be incredibly focused and not exactly
where you're going and let absolutely
nothing swerve you we have we cannot fit
I don't understand facial expressions
very well I'm not very good I don't
interact very well I don't socially
interact very well I'm quite clumsy and
awkward and really really uncomfortable
but my wife is brilliant at it so she
calls me through it
I'm able to compartmentalize the
emotional things I can put it in a box
we prefer working with computers and
people yeah yeah ice and easy answer
than one not because I don't like people
I do I just feel really I'm just waiting
for me to put my foot in it and say the
wrong thing and it's a pressure
are there any specific types of
technology that really excite you most
of it actually there were there were so
many advances I do think we take things
for granted when I started there was no
media there's no we're making machines
talk to each other no synchronization of
any kind other than manual no sampling
it was so different it's just and yet I
do my guilty of taking different granted
as well but we shouldn't you know I'm
never talking to an old girlfriend of
mine her sister said to me a really long
time ago this it's really boring the
world now isn't that nothing exciting
happens and I think couldn't be more
opposite you know something exciting
happens every day you know there's
something new coming along which it
which actually is pretty mind-blowing
[Music]
now since the last e3 Awards a year ago
we've seen the launch of some new gaming
devices some have made more headlines
than others but as tonight is all about
honoring the best we asked our gaming
expert Simon Miller to pick his favorite
hardware for the past 12 months while
it's not unusual for a hardware
manufacturer to release updated versions
of their console a few years after
launch it has to be said that the Xbox
1s is among the best in history now for
starters it is smaller it's thinner it's
gonna look a lot more pleasant under
your TV but there's more stuff in it as
well the controller is better you've got
4k gaming its HDR compatible on top of
that too it's an excellent blu-ray
player and Microsoft was so happy with
it you try and find the original Xbox
one now you won't be able to and even if
you could you shouldn't buy the Xbox 1s
is fantastic and a reason why these big
companies do make iterations years after
the original comes out when the oculus
rift was first released the people
behind it one of you to play with an
Xbox 360 controller and that was fine
we're all used to a paired light men
that didn't feel too alien it was
comfortable however in terms of the VR
experience it's not what you wanted you
wanted something more immersive and your
warden something where you could
actually see your hands
within the VR experience that's what the
oculus touch does
now the greatest thing about this piece
of tech is that when you do put that VR
headset on and you do find yourself in
other world you can look down and not
only can you see your hands they will
react to whatever you do so if you make
a fist
you'll make a fist if you point your
point you ever wanted to get lost within
a video game this is the only way to do
it if you do go back and start using a
controller again you regret it it's not
the same so basically if you want an
oculus rift you've got to get the oculus
touch as well because it is among one of
the best pieces of hardware released in
the last 12 months Nintendo's 2d SXL on
paper doesn't really seem like that much
of an improvement over the 2d yes they
released a few years ago but it
absolutely is no one throughout the
entire gaming industry is as good as
coming up with hardware that is
accessible as a Nintendo does and this
is basically what the 3ds was but it's
for kids it's cheaper and you can give
it to a young one and they can smash it
around and enjoy the games on it you're
not gonna have to buy another one
anytime soon because they're built to
last
the major improvement here is obviously
the biggest screen but it's the whole
package overall which makes this such a
success
Nintendo knows what they're doing and
also they know how to make a handheld
device that is going to appeal to a lot
of people carrying on with that
sentiment we do get to what is the best
hardware release of the last 12 months
and that is of course the Nintendo
switch
for starters no other video game company
would have come up with this to begin
with and they certainly wouldn't have
executed it as well as a Nintendo have
here because not only is it a portable
machine meaning you can play it on the
go but you can also dock it in the
docking station and then play it on your
television so no matter where you are if
you want to play some Nintendo games you
can do that on a Nintendo switch on top
of that it's just a lot of fun to play
you pick it up and it reminds you of
being a kid and it reminds you of why
you love video games so much in the
first place a Nintendo switch is awesome
I've got one you should go get one too
well that's it for this week's white
from the 2017 t3 Awards I hope you can
join us again for more swype next week
and in the meantime follow us on twitter
at sky news swipe bow i
[Applause]
[Music]